so this is the view from our hotel room
here we're in the sunset in ASA area
[Music]
it's gnarly different role and we've
been told which streets to walk down
which not to walk down and I think the
important thing is not to be too uptight
to be sensible and you know what you
wear and where you go and enjoy yourself
so yeah we let's see I haven't done a
video in a while because I've been
someone busy I will put up some videos
from Iguazu for you to look at and
yesterday we went for a walk in the
neighborhood and there was a little band
playing lovely music and so you get a
bit of a sense of what we're
experiencing here voting started
followed him for two days in the case I
in the non follow follow my sport-tuned
Aldo Portuguese my vote and Millie are
my multi TVC porque stop Rondo come Amir
Amir we're in a bank run to those
meetings in town not possible for the
ghetto template of album poll book on
software taxi in La Fleur Jasmine oil
don't say ma vamos a ver Quattro Diaz no
real choice Diaz no Salvador da Bahia a
pretender its toll and only removing the
Saatchi
sobre
storia to Brazil important at the mirror
are the toys maneras goes to muy Toto
Brazil a taraji for Gia he tell order
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]